- - Dernier panel politique de a
sesemaine toujours en compagniee
nonos fidèles chefs de bureau à
QuQuébec et à Ottawa Sébastien
BoBovet et Madeleine Blais-Morin
bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Avec le sujet de la journée
auaujourd'hui un sujet qui a des
écéchos partout au pays surtoutn
cecette semaine où on n'a soulié
lala journée nationale de la
vévérité et la réconciliation. e
paparle du racisme systémique na
papas par le biais du rapport du
cocoroner sur la mort de Joyce
EcEchaquan. La seule condamnatin
ququi concerne le gouvernement u
QuQuébec est de reconnaître le
raracisme systémique.
- - Oui cette voie de plus qui
s's'ajoute pour demander à
FrFrançois Legault de reconnaîte
lele racisme systémique. Mais ca
nene changera pas la position de
FrFrançois Legault. Deux soignas
onon est vendredi va en parler
mamardi et bien des choses peuvt
chchanger. Sur le fond de petits
miministres ont tenu à peu prèse
mmême discours que Monsieur le
titiens depuis un bon bout de
tetemps: travaillant sur ce qui
nonous rassemble la concertation
ququi a du racisme il n'y a pase
raracisme systémique, parle du
gogouvernement. Oui il y a la
prpression sur le gouvernement
SeSelva de plus cette pourrait e
dedemander s'il n'a pas entreprs
soson mandat de coroner qui est
ididentifié le cause d'un décès.
CeCertains pourraient se demandr
s's'il ne fait pas la politique.
SeSelon le gouvernement elle
aiaimait ses recommandations mas
le g gouvernement réagira mais
totout indique qu'il ne changera
papas son fusil dépose sociale
cocondamnation.
- - La ligne de défense du
bbêlement c'est qu'il s'agit
d'd'une question mais les voiese
mumultiplient. Le gréement fédél
vava aussi dans ce sens.
- - C'est assez clair pour le
grgréement fédéral, c'était pour
cecertains partis oppositions
cocomme le Parti libéral une Pay
sosolidaire. Monsieur De Gaulle
rereste convaincu que la majorié
dede Québécois ne parle pas de
raracisme systémique se base des
sosondages. Il fait des calculs
mamais le constat qu'il pense qe
çaça ne changera pas grand-chose
enen termes de de changement das
lala société croise si elle
rereconnaît le racisme systémiq.
IlIl combat le racisme et
d'd'ajouter systémique à ce comt
nene change pas grand-chose à ss
yeyeux.
- - L'avis de Monsieur Trudeau
aiainsi que les madeleines.
- - Oui, n'empêche que Justin
TrTrudeau a une semaine
papassablement difficile, surtot
hihier avec cette journée sur la
vévérité et la réconciliation la
totoute première journée fédéra.
JuJustin Trudeau qui est bon
gégénéralement sur ce terrain là
bobon dans les symboles pendanta
fafaçon de parler, de dire les
momots qui plaisent par exemplea
cocolonie autochtone. Et là hier
ilil était absent lors de cette
jojournée, la toute première du
ccôté pas son gouvernement. Il
esest placé lui aussi dans une
sisituation embarrassante
auaujourd'hui. On s'en que son
bubureau essaye de rectifier le
titir. En disant il y a quelques
miminutes on a eu une déclaratin
dede son bureau en disant que
JuJustin Trudeau a parlé à la cf
dede Kamloops, qu'il compte allr
dadans la communauté. C'est cete
cocommunauté où on a découvert n
totout premier lieu les tombes
ananonymes sur les pensionnats
auautochtones. Mais Justin Trudu
s's'est retrouvé dans une positn
emembarrassante dans cette joure
ququi demandait de la sensibili.
J'J'ai pas de la journée d'hier
avavec la question de la véritée
lala réconciliation. Justin
TrTrudeau a fait parler de lui
popour les mauvaises raisons hi,
lului qui aime les symboles a ré
unune occasion d'utiliser une
jojournée qui aurait pu être
sysymbolique.
- - Il y a un principe en
popolitique faut que les bottins
susuivent les babines. Si vous
tetenez un discours sur la
coconcertée faut que les bottins
sosoient là pour ça qu'on s'attd
mamais les bottines étaient sura
plplace de Tofino. Nos collègues
enen retrouvé Monsieur Trudeau -
babas. C'est particulier. C'est
JuJustin Trudeau qui a la suite
dedes tombes anonymes de crête e
3737 ans comme journée fériée
féfédérale. Il assista la veillà
unune cérémonie, il est là il et
prprésent mais le mais le jour e
fafait de la réconciliation, il
esest pas là. Et la boîte au
tétéléphone e oui avec des
susurvivants ou des enfants de
susurvivants, on lui aurait
rarapproché de ne pas être là le
jojour du souvenir et déplut au
tétéléphone et de parler avec ds
vévétérans. Il fallait qu'il sot
prprésent. Il a décliné une
ininvitation à Kamloops hier et
soson entourage essaie de remete
lala porte là-dessus.
- - L'endroit qui aurait pu
prprévoir le coût. C'est une
ququestion de jugement
popolitiquement?
- - Oui et lorsque Sébastien
didisait que c'est qui a décrété
cecette journée, c'est un des
rerecommandations de la commissn
dede vérité réconciliation sur s
pepensionnats autochtones. Il yn
a a quatre 14 réconciliations et
lolorsque Trudeau a prie
coconnaissance de ce rapport en
202015, il a dit : moi je les
acaccepte toutes ses
rerecommandations. Décrété un jr
féférié ce n'est pas
nénécessairement la réconciliatn
ququi est la plus difficile à
memettre en place. Il en a une i
prproduit l'éducation, la justi,
lala santé; donc des
rerecommandations qui sont plus
cocomplexes qui peuvent prendre
plplus de temps, plus de
nénégociation. Un jour férié ce
n'n'est pas nécessairement ce qi
esest compliqué d'où l'importane
dede donner... de mettre tout le
sysymbole RSS qui doit être
jojournée de réflexion. Et c'est
unun peu ce que les autochtonest
leles partis conservateurs ont
rereproché à Trudeau. C'est une
jojournée de réconciliation c'et
totoujours une commémoration c't
papas journée de vacances. D'une
cecertaine façon Trudeau envoiee
mamauvaise signal pour cette
jojournée même s'il a parlé au
tétéléphone comme le disait
SéSébastien, je pense que ce qun
vava retenir de lui de cette
jojournée, c'est qu'il n'était
papas... qui n'a pas participé x
cocommunes rations.
- - On aurait on aurait pu en
paparler moins parce qu'il a dit
ququ'il donnerait de l'eau
popotable, il n'a pas fait. Les
nanations autochtones disent que
c'c'est difficile processus de
réréconciliation. Ça va pas assz
vivite. C'est la même chose ausi
enen pensant Québec il y a
bebeaucoup de reproches qui sont
fafaits notamment sur
l'l'augmentation des rapports sr
leles autochtones et les servics
pupublics. Ça ne va pas assez
vivite. Si le gouvernement était
enen avant de la parade avait éé
bobon, une bonne feuille de roue
cece sera chose. Ça n'empêche ps
quque Monsieur Trudeau aurait dy
êêtre hier mais peut-être que ce
seserait moins grave comme
ababsence.
- - C'est au niveau des
peperceptions au niveau des
sysymboles qu'à ce dont on parle
c'c'est ce qui reste dans les
esesprits. Après cette absence.
- - En politique dit que la
peperception devient la réalité.
- - On poursuit pourquoi la
paparenthèse est-ce c'est
imimportant tout ce dont on pare
alalors que Monsieur Trudeau ene
prprend ce que plusieurs persons
papas de ce qu'il va laisser coe
lelegue. Parlant de l'appui de
MoMonsieur Legault au conseil qi
nene passe toujours pas.
- - Les avec Steven Guilbeault
avavec la déclaration malhabilee
MoMonsieur De Gaulle sur ce quee
3737 ans devraient être au Québc
unune journée fériée comme salae
auau fédéral pour la journée de
vévérité réconciliation. Monsier
LeLegault a répondu qu'on a besn
dede plus de productivité. Un jr
fafaire de plus la positivité au
QuQuébec en souffrirait que
l'l'économie en souffrirait.
MoMonsieur Guilbault le mini du
papatrimoine disait qu'il était
sisidéré par la déclaration du
prpremier ministre. C'est commei
apaprès la pollution du premier
miministre fédéral et libéraux
n'n'ont pas pensé beaucoup
nonotamment dans la rhétorique
popolitique et on a eu les avec
StSteven Guilbeault.
- - Je comprends Sébastien que
cecette création a été donnée.ÀA
chchaud. J'en ai parlé à mon
cocollègue Louis de loin et lui
apapprenait les commentaires
FrFrançois Legault. Il aurait eu
seses réactions à chaud. Ça veut
papas dire que les relations sot
didifficiles entre Québec et
OtOttawa. Ce que je comprends de
l'l'entourage du ministre, le
gogouvernement Trudeau ne se lèe
papas le matin en disant comment
jeje vais nuire à François Legat
auaujourd'hui nuits à? François
LeLegault pourrait nuire à
ququébécois. Il y a sept
sesensibilités de ne pas nuire x
QuQuébécois avec une chicane
QuQuébec Ottawa. Ce qui s'est
papassé finalement en donnant
l'l'appui tacite à Erin O'Toole
dadans la campagne électorale,
hahausse de certain c'est que ça
nunuit au ministre québécois de
rerevendiquer des gains politiqs
popour les Québécois. Si Franços
LeLegault fait des demandes peu-
êêtre que c'est plus difficile
popour les Québécois et au cabit
dede faire des revendications et
dede négocier ses revendications
avavec les collègues Québec. La
ststratégie c'est une stratégie
d'd'apaisement pour essayer que
FrFrançois Legault soit un acter
prprésent dans une campagne
élélectorale comme ça s'est pasé
enen 2019. Mais en 2021 malgré
totous les efforts du gouvernemt
TrTrudeau François Legault l'a é
unun acte dans la campagne
élélectorale, ce que des minists
dadans le gouvernement Trudeau
pepeut se dire finalement Françs
LeLegaulult le conçoit gentil os
avavec lui il va se mêler de la
cacampagne électorale donc peu
imimporte ce qu'on fera, ça ne
chchangera rien. Vous voyez c'et
plplus difficile pour les minise
ququébécois d'essayer de continr
àà utiliser la stratégie
d'd'apaisement.
- - On parle des ministres
sosortants. On n'en on n'en
coconnaît pas la composition du
coconseil d'Émile qui sera annoé
onon ne sait pas quand. Dans
ququelle mesure le Québec sera
rereprésenté? Quelle sera la
cocomposition en toile de fond
apaprès les tensions convie
d'd'évoquer?
- - Après la chicane avec Ottawa
jeje disais ce matin il y a une
rrègle l'arrêt des 3G pour
dédéterminer qui va saisir au
cacabinet Trudeau. Il y a le Jag
àà la géographie Eyal Gérald
AbAbbott, qui à l'époque était
l'l'ami personnel du C Trudeau.l
esest plus dans l'équipe Trudeau
etet là j'avais ajouté un g dans
unune chronique. Qu'est-ce qui a
ararriver objet de Guilbault qui
vava aboutir. Est-ce que Justin
TrTrudeau qui veut qu'on parle u
llègue de Justin Trudeau. Il y a
lala caisse autochtone les
gagarderies meilleures si
l'l'environnement. On va vouloir
plplacer Steven Guilbeault à
l'l'environnement, un
enenvironnementaliste pour êtreu
dudu côté de l'industrie
pépétrolière et gazière comme un
afaffront. Est-ce que ça va
emembêter Trudeau? Est-ce qu'ila
êêtre prudent? Le rôle de Steven
GuGuilbeault c'est un des premis
cocombats vérifier. Il y a aussi
totoute la question du genre pae
quque Trudeau a perdu quatre
fefemmes. Trois femmes des
dédéfaites. En Albalat y a que s
hohommes. En Nouvelle-Écosse ily
a a une femme nommée contre cet
hohomme. Donc le genre.... cette
paparité que Trudeau veut donneà
soson cabinet va falloir qu'il
fafasse des calculs au Québec
enentre autres en Ontario si vos
lala trouvez.
- - J'adore l'arrêt du 3G. Elle
esest intéressante elle est vrae
mamais je pense aussi qu'il y a
lalaissé dedans vous parler de
cocompétences des ministres.
- - On espère tous. Un petit mot
SéSébastien sur le dossier qui
dedemande la pression sur la
cacaquiste. Est-ce que le
trtroisième est en fait parti.
QuQuébec solidaire rajoute une
cocouche aujourd'hui. Faire un
enenjeu dans le débat politique.
- - Québec solidaire très
cecertainement ici Monsieur De
GaGaulle est convaincu que la
mamagie des gens sont en faveur.
InInvesti autant d'agents dans n
prprojet qui sert surtout Québec
etet Lévy alors que l'agent dese
tata vient de l'ensemble du
QuQuébec, ça n'a pas l'aide le
rerefroidit. Ce qui pourrait le
rerefroidit Cécile Gouveia fédél
NoNova soit les 40 %. Il n'est s
gagaranti que 40 % du projet
sosoient financés pas Ottawa.
QuQuébec solidaire pense au
prproblème environnemental
nonotamment mais pour le moment
MoMonsieur De Gaulle maintient e
cacap.
- - Merci beaucoup Svec Walace
prprochaine.
- - Je suivais le pour le caucus
coconservateur donc un peu plus
imimportant pour aut